this right here is the flex mirror a
portable display that's not only battery
powered but it's also working wirelessly
as you can see right here extending the
display of this new galaxy book Ultra
laptop now while this is a sponsored
video this product is extremely useful
for those who want a portable monitor
with no cables especially for this price
on top of that the specs are actually
quite impressive since this comes with a
Samsung OLED display which is quite a
bit more expensive than LCD and it has
100 DCI P3 color gamut now it's
definitely not perfect because for that
low price there are some compromises in
my opinion but let's get into the
positives first the nice thing is the
design because it's very very thin it's
extremely lightweight only 1.3 pounds is
very familiar and portable which means
you can take it basically anywhere and
it comes with this extra case and stand
so you can prop It Up watch movies
anything you'd like it supports many
devices that run on either the Android
or Windows based operating systems like
let's say phones tablets and laptops all
you got to do to get it to work is pair
it within the Bluetooth settings on your
device then for example on a laptop just
hit the Windows key plus K it'll show up
the casting screen pair it connect it
and there you go it's all set up you can
easily extend the displays and then you
can drag and drop Pages files whatever
over to the monitor like let's say a
YouTube video onto this display and you
can even use it as a touch screen to
control things like the video timeline
you could pause play whatever else just
like a touchscreen tablet but on the
wireless monitor it even supports one of
my favorite features out there Samsung's
deck so right now you can see I'm in the
Bluetooth menu I'm connecting it to this
display and there you go easy as that we
have it right here on the monitor
already Dex is opening up and there you
go we're watching a video on this
massive display instead of these small
display of the phone and by the way the
quad speakers are actually really good
and as you can see it also supports
Apple products like iPads and MacBooks
but you're gonna have to use the
included USBC cable and it's just the
display and doesn't function as a touch
screen on top of that it even works with
a Nintendo switch for gaming which is
pretty cool as well now in terms of some
of the other specs it does have an OLED
display with a 700 000 contrast ratio of
course there's the DCI P3 color gamut
1080p quality to help with the battery
life 300 nits of brightness and it does
have the symmetrical even looking bezels
which is great the aspect ratio is 16x9
which is perfect for watching videos and
movies making it a great sidekick for
your phone to watch video shows anything
you want much better than holding a
phone in your hand and watching and of
course since it's wireless you can pick
it up set it anywhere you want nothing
holding you back and finally it comes
with a 7 000 milliamp hour battery which
is large lasting up to five to six hours
depending on if you're connected
wirelessly so basically the value that
you get for the money is great for a
portable wireless monitor especially
with the OLED display quality and you
can even use it as a preview monitor for
your camera with an HDMI to USBC cable
and now let's finish off with some of
the compromises due to it being offered
at a low price and keep in mind that
these are my own opinion and some of you
might not think it's a big deal now
first of all to me the display is a bit
reflective and kind of tinted a bluish
gray so it can be a bit distracting and
you might not fully see the true OLED
blacks not being perfectly black and
another downside to being portable in my
opinion is that the refresh rate is
limited to 30 Hertz when in Wireless
mode so it can look a little bit jittery
when using it so I'd recommend the
wireless mode for doing things like
watching movies since the refresh rate
doesn't need to be much above 24 but
thankfully when you're using a cable it
works at 60 so that's great one thing I
did notice was that the charging speed
was a little bit slow but the battery
life was great and finally when
connected to an iPad Pro it just mirrors
the display and you can't use it as a
touch screen so it's not as useful but
that might be with the iPad software
itself instead of just the tablet since
this works great with Android and
Windows products so there you guys go
I'd say that for them for the money
those looking for a portable wireless
monitor should definitely check this one
out thanks to being an OLED display and
all of the other features of course so
go ahead and check it out using the link
in the description below for more info
on how to order thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
foreign